استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه السيطره على
خير سون وتحديدا على مدينه خرسون ليس امرا
عاديه في هذه الحرب لا للروس ولا للوكران
هذا ما يفسر هذا الاحتشاد الكبير
للمواطنين الاوكران في مدينه خرسون بعد
ايام قليله من انسحاب القوات الروسيه التي
سيطرت على هذه المناطق لعده شهور منذ
بدايتها هذه الحرب الان استعاده القوات
الاوكرانيه السيطره على حوالي 30% من
مساحه مقاطعه همم خيرسون بعد سيطره روسيه
كانت فيها الاوضاع صعبه للغايه كما يقول
الاوكران برز هنا او ظهر في هذه السيطره
الروسيه على هذه المنطقه محاولات روسيه
لانفصال الانفصال غير سون وانفصال عده
مناطق في جنوبيه وجنوبيه شرقيه اوكرانيا
منها محاوله الاستفتاء يقول الناس الان
الاوكراني يقولون ان محاوله الاستفتاء
كانت همم محاوله فاشله من قبل القوات
الروسيه للسيطره على هذه المناطق لان
الاستفتاء بذلك في تلك المرحله كان مفروضا
على الناس بالقوه اذا كانت القوات الروسيه
وفقا ما يقوله هؤلاء تحاول فرض عمليه
الاستفتاء وكان الامر جاء بقرار ان الشعبي
من هؤلاء يقول الان الناس بانه هذا الخروج
الى الشوارع يعد استفتاء على هذا الذي
تريده ما يريده الاوكران قبل قليل كان
الرئيس الاوكراني بالاوديمازنسكي يتحدث عن
مواصفه وجرائم حرب انتهاجتها القوات
الروسيه وتعذيب في هذه المناطق وقال بان
الخطه التي وضعتها القوات الاوكرانيه
لاستعاده السيطره على المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها قوه الروسيه هذه خطه تسير وفقا ما
هو مخطط وان العمليه الاوكرانيه الدفاعيه
هي التي دفعت القوات الروسيه من الانسحاب
وتركت مدينه تاخير سون بيدي القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تتواعد بانها ستواصل
تقدمها حتى استعاده كل المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها القوات الروسيه الجنوبيه البلاد
صهيب العصا الجزيره من مدينه خيرسون
جنوبيه اوكرانيا